hi dfs you feel so far away
my bffs hello how are you today
okay well it is day two of craft week
here on our show
i love the smell of hot glue in the
morning
so all week long we are celebrating the
art of crafting and when it comes to
crafting
we have to be intrepid which is our word
of the week yes
and it means characterize by resolute
fearlessness fortitude and endurance
bam so let's get our crafting on
crafting exploded this year when we were
all staying home and trying to stay
occupied
aka saying
to kick things off today we want to
introduce you to a pair of creative guys
who are not only an adorable couple
but also professional crafters and they
come up with the most
incredible creations on their instagram
ticktalk
and on the hgv handmade youtube channel
please welcome andrew boza and dennis
cece ducati hello
[Applause]
hi did i get your last name
correctly pronounced yes
you nailed it you nailed it oh gosh it's
very important for me to get that right
and you know sometimes it anyway and you
guys are so important in the crafting
world and i can't believe you're
actually here today
so much so we did a reverse parallel
universe entrance just to be with you oh
my god it's so crazy it's an
honor it's an honor this come about
oh my gosh well we met about 10 years
ago on the national tour of fiddler on
the roof
and there we found we had a mutual love
of crafting decorating and all things
diy
so we put that love into a blog yeah and
in my chucky we're actually not
lumberjacks but we found the name from
this
drunk guy who cat called us lumberjacks
when we were walking to the theater
because we had to have long beards and
we were wearing plaid
and we were trying to think of what we
were going to name our blog and it just
kept cracking us up and little did we
know we'd stick with it
for eight more years and here we are
yeah we're very more sure i think it
really works okay now
i know you guys typically work together
but today we're gonna do something
really special we're gonna separate you
guys
and put you guys in a crafty lumberjack
battle okay
so you're surrounded by crafting
supplies and you each must create a
one-of-a-kind creation using
these supplies um which everything looks
so great you guys thank you
and the theme is wall decor and
the winner will have their creation i
would be honored
to put it up on our dressing room wall
yeah
so that any guests who come through um
can be
and live in it and there's more you must
each incorporate this is so fun by the
way
um a curveball material in your creation
which is a
cat toy yes
um now i know you guys are proud cat
dads right
yes very proud oh my gosh you guys are
i'm
literally like oh you are so wonderful
and you're like
cuteness together i can't take it thank
god we're here throughout the show
together and your cat's name by the way
is teddy krueger
that's right yes also the cutest thing
are you guys competitive with each other
or do you work together
when it comes to our cat yes but we
really don't have the chance to be
competitive against each other too often
so we're really excited about yes ready
bring it this is the perfect chance
let's do this okay are you ready
ready yes on your mark set
craft all right all right guys
this is so fun and we will check in with
them throughout the episode
let's check in with our lumberjack
couple how's it going guys
it's going all right you know we we live
in a one bedroom apartment with no space
we usually craft on the floor so having
a nice table is a luxury for us
so we're just enjoying ourselves oh gosh
i can't wait to see what you're making
and
every time i check in with you it makes
me want to cuddle
oh nuzzle frankie and all of extra hard
today
let's check in on our crafty lumberjacks
andrew and dennis
the diy deadline is almost here how's it
going guys
it's going all right i haven't burned
myself with the glue gun yet so i'm
doing okay
well we still have time good i love a
little
hot glue all right um i'm so excited you
guys are here oh
my god well all right it's the moment of
truth first of all guys i want to show
you what i made over there
with joy cho what do you think beautiful
it's beautiful if like a six-year-old
did this i'd be like good
no i feel like that style is so in right
now well you know thanks guys
all right i am very excited to see your
reveal of the creation that you've been
making throughout the show
andrew what'd you make all right so i
was trying to think of like a dressing
room and we live
like i said in a one-bedroom apartment
and we don't have a lot of room so we're
always thinking
like function yeah so what i created was
uh this little wall organizer i used uh
the
cane wicker which is really in right now
and
i just took the canvas uh frames and
then took off the canvas and then
wrapped the cane wicker around it
stapled it and added a little bit of
detail with paint
and then added some magnets and i used
the cat toys
as the magnets so then if your future
guests they have like an upcoming yard
sale or they need a babysitter or
something they can post it right here
or like you need milk yes exactly oh my
gosh so they're beautiful and functional
yes and this one has a little pocket
put your mail in there dennis what you
got oh gosh i i didn't do as much here i
did a boho inspired
triangle wall hanging it also can double
as a necklace
or a belt if one of your guests needs uh
an accessory
and then for the cat toys i just did a
little tassel here so even if you have a
cat
in the green room they can play it also
triples as a cat toy
wow oh no
trying to sell it this is really hard
and i have to tell you i am like mrs
etsy like i live for etsy anyone who's
on etsy by the way is mrs etsy
um but this i mean i really could see
this this is
obviously this is just beautiful work
gosh
you know what let's wait till we get
right back
[Music]
it's a cliffhanger we're back with the
crafty lumberjacks and we're about to
crown the winner
of our craft challenge and the winner is
it's both of you of course it is okay
and i will tell you why because both of
these things
actually work very well together they're
tone on tone and just like you they
should not be separated thank you thank
you
gentlemen thank you for watching
[Applause]
[Music]